الى التطورات على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه حيث اعلن حزب الله ان مقاتليه
استهدفوا جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
محيط ثكنه ميتات بالاسلحه المناسبه وافاد
مراسل الجزيره باطلاق ثمانيه صواريخ من
جنوب لبنان باتجاه مواقع عسكريه اسرائيليه
في محيط مستوطنه سعسع هذا وقد شنت
الطائرات الاسرائيليه غارات على محيط بلدا
ميس الجبل وعيت الشعب وراميه في القطاع
الاوسط من جنوب لبنان واعلن حزب الله ان
اثنين من مقاتليه استشهد من في هذه
المواجهات من جهته اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه نفذ سلسله غارات جويه على اهداف داخل
الاراضي اللبنانيه خلال ساعات الليل وصباح
اليوم وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف
مواقع عسكريه وبن تحتيه عمليه تابعه لحزب
الله وكانت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه قد
اعلنت عن تعرض بلدتي متات ودفي الحدوديتين
في الجليل الاعلى لاطلاق قذائف من جنوب
لبنان في الاثناء اعلن المجلس الاعلى
للبلدات الاسرائيليه في الجليل الاعلى
اغلاق كافه الطرق ومداخل البلدات في هذه
المناطق المتاخمه للحدود مع
لبنان من بلده رميش جنوبي لبنان معنا من
هناك مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن ابراهيم ومن
الجليل الاعلى مراسله الجزيره فاطمه خميسي
اهلا بكم ابدا مع معك مازن في الساعه
الماضيه كانت هناك مشاهده او متابعه
لتحليق مكثف لطائرات الاستطلاع
الاسرائيليه التي كانت متواجده
قبل في الواقع عبد القادر نحن اليوم ازاءه
ثلاث عمليات حتى الان اعلن حزب الله رسميا
عن تبني احدى هذه العمليات وتحديدا باتجاه
سكنه متات حيث قال بانه نفذ هجوما باتجاه
جنود للمشاه الاسرائيليين ولكن بالاضافه
الى هذا الهجوم هجوم يمكن الحديث عن
هجومين اضافيين حتى الان ننتظر البيانات
الرسميه من حزب الله كي يعلن عن تفاصيل
هذه الهجمات الهجوم الاول باتجاه مستوطنه
دفيف حيث سجلنا صباحا اطلاق صاروخ بذلك
الاتجاه بالاضافه الى ثمانيه صواريخ
رصدتها واطلقت باتجاه مواقع عسكريه في
الاحراج المحيطه ب مستوطنه سعسع وبالتالي
يمكن الحديث عن مجموعه من التطورات
بالاضافه الى هذه العمليات حيث سجل سجلت
غارات عنيفه شنها الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي في محيط بلدتي عيتا الشعب
وراميه هنا في القطاع الاوسط من جنوب
لبنان سجلنا اكثر من سته غارات متتاليه تم
تنفيذها من خلال الصواريخ اطلقت على مناطق
حرجيه بين البلدتين وغالبا ما كانت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقوم باستهدافها كذلك
الامر باتجاه بلده ميس الجبل حيث تم اطلاق
صواريخ من هناك
باتجاه استهدفت ب غارات واطلقت الصواريخ
بذلك الاتجاه اي باتجاه بلده ميس الجبل
ايضا المدفعيه الاسرائيليه قامت بعده
استهدافات على طول هذا الخط الحدودي
وبنظره عامه عبد القادر يمكن القول باننا
اذاء معادله كبيره ثابته ولكن القواعد
قواعد الاشتباك متغيره يوميا بمعنى اننا
اذاء متغيرات تحدث بشكل يومي يطور كل طرف
تقديراته لكيفيه الرد على العمليات التي
تحصل ومن هنا ينبغي الحديث عن مجموعه من
النقاط ابرزها الاستهدافات المباشره لعمق
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه وهو ما داب حزب
الله خلال الفتره الماضيه ونتحدث عن
الاسبوعين الماضيين عن توجيه صواريخه بشكل
مباشر ليس فقط الى المواقع العسكريه
الاسرائيليه على طول الخط الحدودي مع
لبنان ولكن في عمق تلك المستوطنات وكان
لافتا بالامس البيان الذي اشار فيه حزب
الله وكانت لغته مختلفه لاول مره هو يقول
بصريح العباره وجهنا الصواريخ باتجاه مبنى
س سكني في
مستوطنه افيفيم وبالتالي استخدام هذا
التعبير المبنى السكني ربطه بان
الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه باتت متكرره لعمق
البلدات اللبنانيه عند المنطقه الحدوديه
وابعد من ذلك في بعض المناطق غير الحدوديه
وبالتالي الاستهدافات للمنازل السكنيه
باتت تتكرر من قبل مسيرات وطائرات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى مدفعيته
وهذا ما بدا يدفع حزب الله الى استهداف
عمق المستوطنات وهو ما تجلى بكل هذا
الحركه المنعدمه في الداخل الاسرائيلي
وتحديدا من هذه المستوطنات وتقطيع الطرقات
على طول الخط الحدودي من الجهه المقابله
للحدود الجنوبيه للبنان